live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions right here in the lobby Chad
and Alexis are with us welcome guys how
are you
welcome welcome where are you from
Kansas City Missouri good to have you
and you're here to do your debt-free
screen we are and how much have you paid
off we've paid off 27 thousand two
hundred and fifty seven dollars very
cool one how long did that take nine
months very good and your range of
income during that time we started at
seventy one thousand and we are now at
eighty one thousand good what are you to
do for a living
I work in corporate payroll as an
administrator I'm a customer service
representative in front how'd you got
$10,000 razors during nine months I'm
working for a good company and working
hard I was suspect so what kind of debt
was the twenty seven thousand mostly the
car car we paid off her car and medical
bills and credit cards how much of it
was car
I'm sorry nineteen thousand nineteen
thousand okay very cool so what happened
nine months ago that made you guys wake
up and go okay we gotta get rid of this
I was about six months after we had our
youngest daughter autumn and we were
looking to buy some land build a house
we had been renting since we've been
married and we were just ready to own a
house and got in touch with her realtor
who thought we were ready thought you
know this will be easy we don't have a
down payment but we'll figure it out
we'll buy something and Chad came to me
right as I was calling the realtor and
he's like you know honey to be honest we
don't have any money
we'd been pain he had gotten a credit
card and that's how he'd been paying for
our bills and I just got upset with
myself because I knew that that's not
how we could be stewards of our money we
really weren't budgeting we weren't
doing the things we should be and our
kids deserved better so I immediately
got online I listened to a lot of
Podcast and just search for financial
podcasts and your name came up and I
think the whole day I was at work that's
all I listen to is any episode of yours
I could find it looks good all day I
came home to Chad and I said yeah I'm
like I want to do that I want to be
there and so I told him this is what
we're gonna do I went out and bought the
Total Money Makeover
we bought a pizza as our Last Supper of
eating out and we read a whole weekend
and finished it and we said this what
we're doing and I got a part-time job
the next week Wow yep
so Chad this this woman of yours comes
walking in and she's on fire she's
little herself on fire what was your
reaction to that well at first I was
like okay yeah we could do it we could
do it and I kind of set out a plan
saying like yeah we'll probably have it
done my next October got into it about
three or four months and she's like
let's do it for July let's get
everything paid off for July and I'm
like I don't know she's very gizelle
intense
yeah she's game on yeah without it not
without a doubt this is she going for
the Super Bowl right here well
congratulations you two
how does it feel to now not have any
payments it's just amazing like just
we've had a couple of like we had to get
some repair work done on our car and
it's just nice just having the money
there and not having to worry about
oh well having debt again right what was
the biggest benefit of this nine months
of strain because when you go through
something that's just intense that you
guys have done it usually polishes some
rough edges off you know I mean it makes
you become something you weren't before
what was the biggest benefit I think
just better communication with each
other really before there was no budget
me looking at the bank account was me
calling Chad and saying do we have money
in the account so I can buy something at
Target I mean that was really the extent
of it and now we can easily look at each
other and we know you know what's there
what's not and just overall just a
better communication our marriage I
would say what do you think should I
think that's definitely a big benefit
from this I know initially like I
felt like the stress was on me the way
of the world you know I had to do on the
budget myself and just I could see a big
change just from whenever we first
started this the first three months were
kind of rough but but we ended up just
polishing it out just perfectly just you
know I can tell her basically anything
and not be worried about it anymore yeah
well the difference is she knows all the
numbers now you're on the same page and
so you don't feel this weird
gulp when she calls and goes I want to
spend money on target it's like crap I'm
failing over here and this woman wants
more money this is I mean it's a weird
thing man and it all of that's gone yeah
that's fog off of your relationship is
gone it's all clear you know that's very
cool congratulations I'm very proud of
you taken very well done very well done
so now you're off to finish in the
emergency fund and save it up the down
payment for the house yeah there we go
right on to the next thing very cool and
we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's book
retire inspired which is the next thing
the next chapter in your book and your
story is to of course continue building
wealth and then you know expand your
generosity to where it's just outrageous
and so the kiddos are with you and how
old are they and what are their names
autumn is 19 months uh-huh and Chase is
five okay very cool 19 and five 19
months and five okay and as five year
old is he getting this is he going to
yell he says he's gonna yell all right
we're watching your buddy we think you
can do it all right Chad Alexis chasing
autumn $27,000 paid off in nine months
making 71 to 81 count it down let's hear
a debt free scream 3
that's exactly how it works right there
now and you can do this too you just
gotta have a reason and in it funny the
different things that give you a wake up
call
and when you get your wake up call it
could just be listening to that
debt-free scream right there that could
have been your wake-up call the
interesting thing is is that some people
don't answer the call some do some do
answer the call but some don't I don't
know what the difference is I don't know
what it is inside of you that makes you
go okay we're gonna do this or ah well
whatever yeah I don't I don't know what
the difference in the apathy and the.you
know the person who just gets they set
themselves on fire and they go crazy
with it
it's absolutely awesome when somebody
decides they're gonna do like Alexis and
Chad just did because they take control
of their lives there's so much dignity
you have when you happen to your money
instead of your monies happening to you
because you're really taking control of
so many different areas of your life
when you do that hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show